PROFESSOR: Okey dokey.
So anybody else with
a specific idea?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: A fighting game that
you control with your head.
PROFESSOR: All right.
AUDIENCE: You have to also--
you have to move your head.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, is
that sufficient to remember?
All right, I don't think we need
any more details on that one.
That seemed to be sufficiently
exciting for folks.
All right, there's another hand.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: A game with your body.
So like, your right hands
that create [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: These are really
well scoped for two days.
I'm quite impressed.
All right, paint with body.
And it would be--
so the right hand is a different
color or a different brush.
And the left hand is a different
color, or a different brush,
or something like that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, all right-- Yeah--
oh, wait, sorry.
We'll start back there
and then come forward.
AUDIENCE: A puzzle box.
And then one hand
would be rotating
through the different
sides of it.
And your right hand would be
like the interactive hand.
PROFESSOR: Oh, funky
like a Rubik's cube type
thing where you have too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but one
hand is how you move around
and the other one's
the interactive side.
PROFESSOR: All right.
All right, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I have a game
where you're like a ninja
and then throwing swords
are being thrown at you.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
attack the attacker
and you're throwing swords back.
PROFESSOR: That is some solid
interaction right there.
All right, ninja--
so two stage--
one is dodge throwing stars.
The second is throw
throwing stars.
All right.
Oh, yeah--
AUDIENCE: What I'm well you
have to indirectly guide
little asteroid characters
into different places,
like a square character into
the square place, a triangle
character into the
triangle place,
the circle character
into the circle place,
but you do it indirectly.
You have no control [INAUDIBLE].
We'd have to find--
I mean, a way to search
people one way or the other.
They behave differently
depending on their physics--
their body physics.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So some indirect--
it's like lemmings.
AUDIENCE: Lemmings or
something like that.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have some sort
of either procedural or
physics base behavior.
And you don't have a
direct-- you can't just
grab it and put it there.
You have to find another way.
Can you blow into the
Kinect or something?
PROFESSOR: I think the
microphone can detect noise
levels, but I don't know
if you could detect blowing
versus just ambient noise.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that would be hard.
[INAUDIBLE] do your
input for that.
AUDIENCE: You'd
have to do something
that is indirect control.
PROFESSOR: All right.
OK.
And the end mechanic would be to
guide them home or something--
to guide them into some place.
AUDIENCE: Into the right place.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
Yeah--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's so sweet.
I just want to help.
No, really, I felt that
one right in my heart.
That was good.
All right.
All right, any other
fun specific-- oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: A racing
game where if you
link to the net and your
car could [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Nice.
That's going to be a really
good educational game
to put together
in order to learn
all the mechanics of what's
happening inside of the Kinect.
That's a really nice
learning project.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Over there.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking of
building a virtual aquarium.
So if you're the scuba diver
and you wave your arms,
the fish get scared and
they flock away from you.
And then they slowly sneak
back and then you move
and it would scare you.
So basically it's kind
of like roll-a-ball,
but the cubes are--
[INAUDIBLE] player.
PROFESSOR: They want to be in
a certain configuration, but--
AUDIENCE: --until you scare
them and they scatter.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Cool.
Yeah, I like what you
called it, virtual aquarium.
It's also good one.
You're going to learn
about area factors
and triggers by doing that.
Any other?
I thought I saw a hand.
No, it was just a
person doing something.
Oh, Glenn, do you want to make
a pitch for your 2D puzzle?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry I'm late.
PROFESSOR: No, that's all right.
I'm sorry to get you
mid adjustment on--
AUDIENCE: I had computer
malfunction this morning, so
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, no.
AUDIENCE: So I'm think trying--
what I've wanted to
do for a long time
is to deploy 2D grid puzzles.
So what I mean by
those are things
like-- if you know
the game of Sokoban.
Tetris is a good puzzle.
So there's a whole range
of these street grids
that have cells.
So you might have a ten
by ten, five by five.
Anyway, so there's a whole
range of good puzzles.
I've tried to design a
bunch of new puzzles.
And I would like to learn
an infrastructure-- software
infrastructure that will
let me quickly build
versions of these puzzles and
deploy them across platform.
And so I'm hoping Unity might
be something [INAUDIBLE]..
So what I'd like to do is--
so are we doing mini projects?
PROFESSOR: Mini projects,
yeah-- mini projects
that utilize the Kinect
in some small way.
That way when you do
your larger project--
yeah, once you do your larger
project, it doesn't have to.
So it could be a grid
puzzle game that you just
move the object around.
AUDIENCE: So what I'm thinking
as a first mini project is just
to try to learn how to
put a grid on the screen--
2D grid.
And have a single element
that moves [INAUDIBLE],,
sort of like roll-a-ball
except-- roll-a-ball,
except that it would move
discretely from one cell
to the next and not dynamically.
If we wanted to get
fancy, eventually we
could try to do animation to
move the ball or the element
from one cell to the
next, but initially I'd
just have it reposition
and jump to a bottom jump.
And so the first
pass is just to be
able to control-- have a
grid, represent the grid,
control the ball,
and move it around.
That's simple, but simple things
sometimes take a long time
when you're creating software.
If we get beyond the
first stage of that then I
think we'll have a simple game
in the past just as an exercise
[INAUDIBLE] target, where you
move the ball to the target
cell and as soon as
you hit the target,
as soon as you get onto the
cell that has the target,
the target will
jump somewhere else
and then move again to
try to get to that target.
So again, it's a
pretty trivial game.
PROFESSOR: I made a
website that did that.
It had a button,
and every time you
clicked it it didn't do the
thing it said, it just moved.
AUDIENCE: Moved the button?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
moved the button.
It just moved itself.
So it was like, submit, submit--
AUDIENCE: And then
the variation of that
that it's not far to get
from an actual puzzle that's
pretty challenging.
So you could put in obstacles
on the grids or certain cells,
you could make a pass through.
You could make a
maze, for example.
You have to get through the
maze to get to get the target.
I developed a version of this
that I call multi-target,
where you have two or
three things that move
and then when you
control them they
all try to move in the same
direction, unless one of them's
hitting an optical or something.
Any that hit opticals
wouldn't move.
So you could use the
opticals cleverly
to change the relative
positions of the moving objects.
The game objective is to get
all of the moving objects
onto the target simultaneously.
So there might be three
targets [INAUDIBLE]
movables and you're
trying to get all three
simultaneously onto [INAUDIBLE].
Things along those lines.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
All right, any other
specific mini projects?
Just you base things--
oh, yeah, awesome--
oops, sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: Where you're-- in a
situation where you're angry
at everyone.
People are trying to comfort
you and trying to help you,
but you just do-- every single
time [INAUDIBLE] hand motions
and then they just fly away.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Just
like, leave me alone.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] they're
trying to be like [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know.
You have make with your
like, with your cursor,
but in this case
you move your hand.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
a little gesture.
Right, right, right--
AUDIENCE: If you do wrong or
not in enough time, then--
PROFESSOR: --they,
like, hug you.
AUDIENCE: They just come closer.
PROFESSOR: I want to make
a comedic joke about it,
but I'm too uncomfortable,
so I'm not going to.
No, I think it is very funny.
And I think a lot of people
will identify very, very
much with it.
I don't know how
to describe that.
The get away game?
The--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The loners dilemma?
AUDIENCE: Shoo--
PROFESSOR: Shoo-- that's right.
Push away-- all right, I'm going
to call it push away affection,
although that may be too
strong of a title for it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, it is good.
So there's some implicit
stuff that has happened here,
which is some of you
are starting to think
about the interaction mechanic.
So you're thinking
about the Kinect
in a nice way, which is you
can map some type of movement
onto an interaction
with the game.
So you can think a
really simple mechanic,
which is like grab, move--
it's exactly like a mouse, and
everything is perfectly fine,
and my mind knows how to do
that because I use mice all day.
But with the Kinect,
you can do these things
like, this means get away
from me, whereas this means
all right, come in for a hug.
And you can start thinking
about very different interaction
mechanics.
And there was
something similar here
where just any type of
wiggle is a-- scare the fish,
which is not
something you normally
think about when you're thinking
of building a video game,
but when you have the
Kinect you can actually
think about these new
interaction models.
AUDIENCE: Does the
Kinect distinguish
between open and closed
[INAUDIBLE],, for example?
PROFESSOR: It does with 70%
accuracy most of the time.
Are you guys saving the--
there was a making
a tree grow game.
Are you saving that
for the large project?
Yeah, all right, sorry.
Never mind, never mind--
forget that I said that.
All right, any other fun
things with different--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, pet
foam puzzle where
you have to navigate
the ball from start
to end without falling off.
But instead of
controlling the ball,
you are going to push the ball.
PROFESSOR: Mhm,
like using force?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so platform--
so you're the God of wind.
And you can push a
gust and it rolls
a little bit in that direction.
You have to redirect it.
Awesome.
So that's pretty good.
We have space for one, two,
three, four, five more.
And they don't have to happen.
So if you have ideas and they
don't happen, no problem.
AUDIENCE: I think I'll
just share the tree one.
So it's actually taken
from the cartoon Totoro
from Studio Ghibli.
In the middle of
the movie there's
Totoro who grows this tree.
So he brings--
[INAUDIBLE] all of his friends,
like the two girls, and they
bow like the Asian-- when
you're praying you bow.
And then as you bow, these
seeds grow into little leaves
and then grows into a
small tree and then grows
into a huge tree.
So it's like another
form of the storytelling.
The little girl's
like, your life is
going to-- you're growing up.
You're going to be in a
different state of your life
soon.
So maybe this game
could be-- as you're
doing what you referenced
with the aquarium
too-- when you're
making a little gesture,
something grows.
PROFESSOR: So anytime you're
hands are together and near
your head or
something like that.
Nice.
AUDIENCE: Like Totoro.
PROFESSOR: Like Totoro.
Did I spell it right?
I just am guessing--
AUDIENCE: Totoro, yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is a really good gesture
that can be easily defined,
which is hands come
near each other.
They come near the head a
certain distance and then
all three drop down.
So you're going to have to
have somebody on your team
you can program to recognize the
gesture, but you have support.
And we can help you get that.
But, yeah, I like
this tree growing one.
To start in the
next two days, you
could just have
gesture recognized
and then have something grow.
And that's the extent of
what you do in two days.
It just keeps growing or as long
as you're holding it it grows.
And that's a really
well scoped four hour
thing to try to
do with the team.
AUDIENCE: This is
similar to the paint
one, but what if it
was pair one instead?
Where instead of painting,
you're [INAUDIBLE]..
The second form of
attraction would be water.
So then you could see which
way water pass through whatever
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Nice.
Terraforming new-- cool.
I don't know if I'll use that
space, but I left it there.
I'm going to throw one
out, which would-- oh, no,
never mind.
I'm not going to say that.
It would be way too complicated.
Forget that-- my brain is
usually too confused to--
AUDIENCE: How good is
[INAUDIBLE] resolving
a position if you jump
from one point to another?
PROFESSOR: Like if
you jump like that?
AUDIENCE: It can see your feet
very well, as long as you point
it down, though, at first.
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking,
maybe, that you can just
make this Super Mario
collapsible bridge thing--
you have to cross a bridge
within a limited time.
Because each [INAUDIBLE],, once
you touch it it would just fall
down and you just have to--
PROFESSOR: I see.
So it's scrolling at you and you
have to jump across the bridge.
AUDIENCE: You have to run
fast and also precisely
on that block,
otherwise you'd miss it
and you'd fail the game.
AUDIENCE: That would
be very doable.
PROFESSOR: --very doable.
I don't know why I wrote the
word adventure, but I did.
I'm going to draw a foot--
a little person's foot.
That's a person and here is--
I don't know if that's--
something like that.
All right, two more.
It's for my OCD.
I don't want to leave part
of the board left uncovered.
It's not necessary, but it
would make me so happy inside.
What's other cool
things that people do?
Food or--
AUDIENCE: How about [INAUDIBLE]
bowling, but there's
obstacles in your way as well?
And so once you
release the ball,
you can also try to change the
direction of the ball by like--
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the actual bowling
that we do where we're like,
yeah, come on,
lead to the right.
That's really good.
You're capturing a very
intuitive interactive
there, which is you roll
it and you go, come on.
OK.
So we're going to
call it real bowling.
AUDIENCE: Jedi bowling.
PROFESSOR: Jedi bowling-- nice.
And then you can have
little mice run out
across because your turning
and you're like, no, no,
don't hit the mouse, no.
All right, and then
there was another hand--
AUDIENCE: Maybe if you had
all little magnet balls--
and I'm not sure if the Kinect's
accurate enough, but to be
able to just play with a
virtual ball of magnets.
PROFESSOR: I would love
it if somebody tried
that for the mini project.
And then if it went fairly well,
did that for the main project.
And then I could tell
a really good story
about how this class
led to the thing
that we built this
class for, which
was to do something that's
an interactive science demo,
and would also feed into
our pitch to make a VR cave
inside of the university.
You nailed it.
You were holding that one
for last and I appreciate it.
So it'll be something-- so it
doesn't do so well on fingers,
but it'll be something
where you can move--
it'd be like as if
you're in a ball pit,
but the balls are
all kind of magnetic
and you can move
them with your body.
And then maybe somewhat very
related to the fish thing.
So just a different
physics that's
governing the flocking
of these objects that
are around your body.
OK, cool.
Anybody feel like
they had one in
and they were too shy
to say it, but now they
feel like they should
because you can?
Nope-- all right.
AUDIENCE: Idea--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this may
be a little advanced
for a [INAUDIBLE] project, but
I'm thinking of 3D rotations
of multi cell pieces, like 3D
Tetris type pieces that could
be--
I assume you can
make pieces in unity
that are pooling together
cubes or something
and so that they
all move together.
And so the idea would
be to just come up
with reasonable Kinect gestures
that would rotate in 3D.
And so the mini
game could be-- it
could be you've got a piece that
you have to match to a target
orientation.
So maybe a little display
shows the orientation
you're aiming for
and you just have
to rotate the piece to get it.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That is good.
And there was another
one over here,
which would have a similar--
AUDIENCE: --puzzle
box, bottom left.
PROFESSOR: Bottom
left-- puzzle box.
Puzzle box, yes-- all right,
so this one was something
like, you have a
box, and you move it,
and you can rotate it
in some meaningful way.
And then this one allows
you to do some interaction.
So maybe you're painting
the sides of a ceramic vase
or something.
So these two would have
very similar mechanics.
All right, so the next
thing is you're all
going to stand up and--
is this going to work
with this many people?
Yeah, we're going to explore.
So you're going to
stand up, and you're
going to come up here, and
make a vote for the ones-- oh,
do you want a picture of that?
Let me get out of the way.
I think there's about
10,000 sales there.
OK.
So come up and do a vote.
So if you are interested in
doing it come-- oh, sorry,
I thought I was
in your way again.
Come up and just put
a little check mark,
which is like, I'm
interested in this thing
and this is going to help us
self-organize in some way.
And we can narrow this down to--
how many people
are in this room?
Three, six, nine,
12, maybe 35 and--
so getting this down to
eight to nine projects.
So you're going to want
to be in a team of three,
but I don't want you instantly
to go like, I already
know somebody so I'm going to
be in their team no matter what.
Try on the mini
project, and then I
won't make you do it
on the big project,
to go based on your interest and
maybe collaborate with people
that you have never talked to.
And it will only be two
days, so it's at worse
going to be two days where you
get to sit and play with unity
and not talk to people that
you don't want to talk to.
So this is the time
to do that experiment.
And you might make a
new friend, who knows.
OK.
You can either come up
and do the check box thing
or find some way to
self-organize around
which project you want to do.
And I know that this will be
chaos for 15 to 20 minutes.
And then once you
organize around a project
that you want to do, start--
well, no.
For 15 or 20 minutes,
try to figure out
who you want to work
with on which projects.
And then we'll come together
and you'll start to refine it.
It doesn't have to be the
exact vision of the person who
wrote it on the
board, but there's
something about one of these
projects that interests you.
Maybe it's you want to know how
to do the hand rotation or arm
rotation type thing.
Maybe it's that you
want to understand
how just to detect this thing
and do flocking algorithms
so objects will move
in a certain way.
So figure out something
about one of these
that interests you.
Go find the other people
who are interested in it
by some method,
and talk to them,
and see if it seems like a
good fit, or if they have--
because you may come up and
somebody's like, I love fish.
And somebody else
is like, I want
to detect motion like this.
And you decide not to work
together because one of you
really just wants to build
fish and the other one just
wants to do body motion.
So try to do something.
I like this chaos.
Should would do the name
game again or do something
to make us more extrovert?
Are we feeling confident?
OK.
On the count of three say a
number between zero and 10,
which represents how introverted
and shy you feel right now.
I'm sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: 10 being what?
PROFESSOR: 10 being like, I am
so ready to-- oh, yeah, right.
You're right.
That would be an
inverse-- all right,
so 10 means I'm just going
to stand up and go hug
a stranger right now.
And zero being, I am just so
terrified to stand up and talk
to somebody right now, not
even the people I know,
do I want to talk to.
So 10 being super
extroverted, zero
being super introverted--
one, two, three, seven.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right,
so five to four.
All right, we're going to
try to get that to a seven
and then we're going to have you
get up and talk to strangers.
So how about we close
our computers now,
and I'm going to walk you
guys through, and then
do a big circle around
the room, and we're
going to do an improv
game to make ourselves
feel a little more extroverted.
And it'll be super
fun, I promise.
So close your computers.
Move the tables to the
center of the room.
Make a big circle
around the room.